is there ever a temptation to overly
sexualize yourself
no but I can totally for me there's not
genuinely there's not but I can see the
appeal of why there is for women your
likes have gone to like your likes have
plummeted whatever Shadow band whatever
you want to call it so you're like okay
whatever I'll put on a swimsuit turn
around and take a picture by the pool
you know I could see the deal bang with
algorithms back up bro like we have the
likes are back to normal but like I
genuinely think for women
the second you start posting pictures of
you know your ass mostly you know or
like a huge cleavage picks whatever it
is on Instagram pictures of you in a you
know nice covering dress will never
perform as well as they did when you're
posting your ass or tits so I did a
podcast probably about three probably
about three years ago with a female
adult actress in the UK and I was asking
her about the typical career progression
of girls that go into this industry and
she'd been in it for like
a decade she's like a older she'd won
awards there's awards for that
apparently I don't know I don't know I
didn't see I didn't watch either the
awards or the content that was submitted
I think it was like a Sundance Film
Festival it must have been anyway so I
was asking her and she basically said
that there's a hierarchy of
um
intensity to different kinds of Pawn
scenes so I think it was like solo girl
on girl guy on girl like all the way
down to like anal DP like it descends
deep uh uh Han not intended
and I kind of feel like there's an
equivalent
uh stack intensity thing to the kind of
content and I don't think that guys can
do the same thing it's like it's a
topless photo for a guy sometimes you
look better like actually you look
better with a shirt on right and you
could be in good condition but you could
look cool with a shirt on yeah it does
feel to me a little bit like
you know as much as we've got this
women are at 35 percent of CEOs new CEOs
income in companies January of 2023 were
women so the highest percentage ever uh
women are out earning man between the
ages of 21 and 29 women are out
educating men two women for every one
man completing a US college degree by
even though we have all of that
there's like still a big undercurrent of
sexualization for women and this isn't
I'm not saying like this is the
patriarchy plowing it on them
very often women choose to sexualize
themselves themselves or each other yes
yeah because it's them largely competing
with other women now it may be for the
eyes of men but if you are hoping for
men to not click on a photo that's got
boobs or a bum in it
I think you're fighting against like the
thermodynamics of like
Sexes no 100 and a thousand times I've
heard girls that and I have no hate on
girls that want to do and only fans or
have and only fans it's not like oh you
have an only fans I'm not your friend
it's not that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying it's not for me and there's ways
I feel about it but that doesn't mean
that I'm gonna dislike you or I'm gonna
hate you or judge you for having one
women say that having an of or whatever
is empowering and I think for me it's
just hard to grasp how that can be
empowering when you're chatting with men
all day or having your management chat
with men all day Vietnamese virtual
assistant yeah surprise guys if you're
if you're subscribed to an of and you
think it's her texting you
it's her fat manager yeah it's not her
yeah yeah I I don't know I I really
think it'll be interesting to reflect on
this period of
monetization for especially women
in 10 years 20 years time and realize
that it was either a brief flash in the
pan or the beginning of a tsunami of
people sexualizing themselves for the
price of a cheeseburger per month I hope
it's
I hope it's not anything that has
longevity to it but I could understand
how it's appealing for a girl that just
has just turned 18 okay fully not
developed in her brain thinks oh my God
I can make five figures a month you know
I have you know I have 20 30k on
Instagram I can make five figures a
month I don't have to go to college I
don't have to be alone for years
um I don't have to go find an actual job
I can post bikini pics and make
equivalent to a teacher or a doctor that
I could understand how that's appealing
you know what's interesting as well I
think I've heard you talk about this
before that it kind of doesn't really
matter what you post on only fans either
because they've tried to do
like comedy on there I think Whitney
Cummings did a roast uh but Christ has
done some uh only fans exclusive content
uh there's a number of girls that I know
who
justify of
um their MO is I post this stuff for
free on Instagram anyway oh yeah
therefore if I just post more a higher
frequency of the same level of nudity on
only fans that's basically I my morals
from Instagram it's already been there
yeah there is nothing different but the
problem it's a branding problem I think
they say that to like you know help
themselves feel like better about it
maybe because it's the for well for me I
can only speak from Mayan but it's the
idea of a paywall platform you know
getting people's money to show whatever
it is that like for me just wouldn't
click but I wouldn't even if I was
posting only gym content and leggings
and a t-shirt yeah just the idea of
it's an interesting one we're chatting
with someone you know there's been a lot
of the intimacy as well I think that's a
part of it yeah but so you know how
vaping is like every every person is
taking nicotine in some form or another
I was having a conversation the other
day about how vaping has probably oh
Retreat of cigarettes and the ascendancy
of vaping has probably been a net
negative for health because vaping is
way more enjoyable than smoking ever was
yeah it tastes better it's cooler
there's no smell no one could know
exactly all of this and it doesn't
smoking that wasn't so good I think if
you go into the
if you start to educate yourself about
health and fitness lots of people are
pushing back against vaping too but I
don't think that's really broken into
the mainstream just yet so a lot of
people do it
I wonder whether
kind of like how vaping is the thin end
of the wedge for nicotine
uh only fans has become a thin end of
the wedge for
porn and for self-objectification
yeah
I don't know I agree with you that I I
struggle to see how
I I don't know it's a tight line about
the the
I'm liberating myself and this is this
is empowering because you are taking
men's money
but is the price of your nudity
like a Double Whopper from McDonald's
and then if it's Black Friday it's like
six chicken nuggets yeah I don't know I
don't know and I
it's something that I have like I have
concerns about and I haven't really
worked out my opinion on yet about like
what this means long term yeah I think
that's really going to be I think long
term I just think if you start
again I'm not sure I it sounds like I'm
just on any woman with an only
fans which I'm not I'm just saying it
from the perspective of a girl who's out
there thinking about it I would
recommend to not start one
that's the only thing I'm that's the
only way I'm coming at this I'm not
on anyone that has one I
wouldn't so another thing I wonder what
it does is I'd seen throughout my 20s
girls that were strippers they really
struggled to see their relationship with
men as anything other than transactional
because
150 times a night
they needed to extract resources from
this guy yeah who was down from
Edinburgh or had flown in from Dublin or
something for a stag weekend with the
boys maybe he was married maybe he was
in a relationship maybe he was whatever
and they saw this relationship with
manners
adversarial as transactional a
short-lived and I saw a a struggle in
their personal lives to rip themselves
out of that and then if you think okay
and that's not even uh protracted or
that intimate
if you don't have the Vietnamese manager
that's messaging all of the people that
you're with and it's actually you that's
doing the uh simp admin probably
with you mentally so how are you able to
determine the line between genuine
emotional connection and like
performative emotional connection do you
know what I mean yeah for sure
yeah I think not just your relationship
with men but like longevity you know
um
especially because it's something like
you know it's not the same as like maybe
a dancer or whatever this is all online
like I feel like it's something you
could never live down and if you're
already an influencer what they're gonna
what people are gonna address you as
like oh the only fans girl
you know it's the stigma that comes Acro
comes with it the title what's happening
with fansley is fansley just only
fansley have you heard of that I haven't
okay so this is like the twitch streamer
equivalent I think I wonder if it it
can't there's no way that twitch would
give it partner access or integration or
whatever but
is something else and I'm seeing a
different cohort of people it's mostly
twitch streamers that are doing that
um and I feel like it's the same it's
like private messages and blah blah blah
but yeah I don't know have you have you
seen the new thing like AI the AI Bots
like you pay per minute to talk to
someone and they use your voice from
your videos or your online personality
to chat with someone yes that's the same
thing like yeah I wonder whether
if I was the guy that made only funds is
British right he's from Essex
if I was him when chat GPT came out and
the AI uh image Creator thing
I would have spent as much money as I
could I would have dumped a ton of
cash into no longer being an agency and
instead becoming a tech product because
if you could vertically integrate
yourself back up and not only be the
service that people go through but be
the creators themselves by making the
girls and by creating the chat Bots and
by owning the algorithms and by owning
the servers you cut out I don't know
what the percentage is did it take 10 or
five percent whatever the day only fans
yeah they think a lot more than that I
think what do they take is it 15 or 20
.
Joe you're always on only fun that's all
that you spend your time you're always
talking keep your money out of only fans
and put it into like one of the
the s p you want to put it in the s p i
don't know I'm not very educated with
stocks I wish I was more educated but
whatever Tesla right put in Tesla cool
Elon Muskie get my money in other news
this episode is brought to you by cozy
Earth we sleep one third of Our Lives do
not spend 33 of your life in anything
other than unbeatably comfortable sheets
getting a good night's sleep is the
Ultimate Game Changer and the sheets
that you have are a massive determinant
of just how comfortable you feel cozy
Earth has the most premium bedding and
loungewear that I've ever found they're
made from super soft viscose from highly
sustainable bamboo temperature
regulating so you will sleep comfortably
all year round and an enhanced weave
quality that won't pill so it's higher
quality will last longer and you will
have a more comfortable night's sleep
and wake up feeling more rested and
revitalized plus there is a 10-year
warranty on all of their products that's
how confident they are that they're
gonna last but don't just take my word
for it Oprah has chosen cozy Earth as
one of her favorite things for five
years in a row now you can get an
exclusive 35 discount site-wide on
everything by going to cozyearth.com
Modern wisdom and using the code modern
wisdom 35 a checkout cozier.com modern
wisdom and modern wisdom a checkout
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that clip with Sarah then press
here for the full length episode go on
press it